l'ambiance on s'amusait ya pu rien à me
mettre ensemble depuis 35 ici je dépense
pas mon quartier des halles le quai aux
fleurs la mégisserie la passerelle
désert carrée du louvre on rigole il
travaille il a refusé d'être déportés je
suis prêt à les porter
on avait notre chère s'était détaché
économique majeur des taliban d'une
cirrhose japonais doivent insee lien
pailhères et bébé je devrai tout le
monde craque
les meubles de la viande matin midi et
soir son chapeau sa cloche et toutes les
cloches tous les méchants vous avez y
encore des déclencheurs des alpes sa
veuve aussi glissé peuvent nourrir vêtir
et des champions
j'avais championnat du monde le grand
bob gainey les indices y avait le coup
qu'on appelait commence on a pu les
appeler pour nous la présentons les
pires la plante grand charles après de
gaulle et puis j'ai pu et je me prends
pour cela il va cernant la wadr nord
devient aveugle
demain verra pas du tout
on trial les voies du rer métro régional
conscient des halles la fait pas déplacé
par ici pourquoi prestation de métro le
matin oui dans ce nouveau ventre de
paris
il y aura d'abord tout au fond un grand
réseau pour la circulation à 35 mètres
sous terre des tunnels seront réservés
au métro express régional et au chemin
de fer
la grande gare du châtelet passeront les
lignes saint germain en laye boissy
saint léger et la liaison ligne de
sauvegarde du nord
les travaux de la ratp sont mené
rondement
on prévoit la liaison effective entre
les différentes ressources actuelles
pour la fin de l'année prochaine ce sera
une étape primordiale pour de meilleures
liaisons entre des différentes banlieues
le métro classique est présent dans ce
chantier
ici ce sera la future station des halles
sur la ligne numéro 4 pour l'instant
c'est un enchevêtrement de ferraille où
viennent se figer des centaines de
tonnes de béton pour l'instant la ligne
numéro 4 passes en corse où la rue
baltard un jour la nouvelle station sera
terminé et l'ondé vire à la ligne numéro
4 cela paraît presque simple
et pourtant cela aurait pu tuer des
centaines d'heures de travail à des
centaines d'hommes et tout le reste est
fort idée matériaux argent beaucoup
d'argent
à qui
nous
je
on va pas
le trou des halles c'est le plus gros
chantier de paris en ce moment 800
ouvriers y travaillent
la plupart venus d'un autre pays et puis
après on put
avec viola
il avait été prévu que c'était comme on
appelle ça une tonne de pyramide
inversée avec les boutiques tout autour
de ma mère
guy castet boutique tout au tout
au fond la gare du rer ensuite le métro
en remontant vers la surface on
retrouvera des aménagements pour des
moyens de transport de moins en moins
collectifs jusqu'à finir par un carreau
en principe réservés aux piétons
mais avant avant d'arriver à ce carreau
qui suscite tant de polémiques
il y aura le forum un ensemble de
commerces et de loisirs
il n'y aura des parkings et pour arriver
dans ces parkings des voies d'accès qui
s'engouffreront tout sous le sol
voilà les ald aujourd'hui une
fourmilière entouré d'un beau monument
saint-eustache d'un gros bâtiment la
bourse du commerce
de nombreux immeubles témoin d'une vie
d'un quartier
et puis dans un coin bien enfermé pour
l'instant la fontaine des innocents
et
c'est les gros armature qu'ils vont
trouver dans l'intégration de ta
personne n'ira voir aussi cet agrément
quelques curieux s'est passé c'est vrai
il ya le passé comme les gadgets en 18
faut pas y rester sur sur son passé il
faut aussi voir ce qui va se faire
il va revenir l'inconnue aujourd'hui ce
sont des projets que préparent les
quatre architectes groupe et comme un
seul homme pour refaire un quart aux
halles le 1er juillet ils devront avoir
rendu leurs devoirs voici leurs
brouillons
après il restera un boucher le deuxième
trou n'est pas les touristes
je vais vous dire un truc secret alors
puisque vous le voulez comme ça il ya
une mare de flotte
leurs visas qui a des gars dont qui nage
dans la mer mais vous seriez et allez
monsieur oui et puis des gardons qui
viennent de la scène et qui sont
apportées par milo et puis c'est le
tripier de la rue berger qu'il met dans
son bac et puis quand ils sont bien
vivants et l'air fou dans la mer par la
suite des gens encore plus sérieux pense
construire dans ce deuxième trou des
halles un central téléphonique est
d'autres équipements quoi qu'il en soit
une fois tous ces trous boucher dans
quatre cinq ans l'ensemble des halles
sera constituée de beaucoup de vie
souterraine de quelques hectares de
verdure en surface verdure entouré
d'immeubles dont l' architecture reste à
déterminer des immeubles qui seront le
symbole d'un certain changement dans la
continuité
et puis il y aura toujours le quartier
car les halles c'est encore tout ce qui
vit autour du chantier
ouais
mais